كما وعد قبل اسابيع غرد الى الماسك الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه تويتر والصحفي ماكل شلن
برجر بالجزء الرابع من الملفات الداخليه
لعملاق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تصلي
الضوء على ما حصل في اليوم التالي لاحداث
السادس من يناير في مبنى الكابيتول هيل
برسالته قبل ساعه على المنصه والمعنونه
بازاله ترامب سبعه يناير
ظهر شلن برجر ان الرئيس التنفيذيه السابق
لشركه تويتر
من مسؤوليته الى رئيس الثقه والسلامه
السابق في تويتر
الموظفين على الاستمرار بالتمسك بالسياسه
منصه لان القررت اخذ لتعليق حساب ترامب
وبررت تويتر ذلك بانه تم تقييم اللغه في
تغريدات ترامب واعتبرت انها تنتهي كل
سياسه تمجيد العنف وان حساب الرئيس ترامب
بويقافه فورا ونهائيا من الخدمه
تغيير في السياسه لانه في حاجتين حصلت في
الفتره هذه اولا انه جاك دورسي ما كان
موجود في تويتر همم خلال الفتره دي فهو
كان خارج البلد ثانيا انه كان في ضغط من
الداخل ومن الخارج هذه الملفات ولم تمر
مرور الكرام لدى الحزب الجمهوري والفريق
القانوني لحزب المحافظين الذين اعتبروها
ادله تثبت المخاوف التي صرح عنها في عده
مناسبات حول كونهن ضحايا للقوائم السوداء
والمنع من التعليق والحج على المنصه على
عكس شهاده المدرنات تنفيذيين للشركات في
جلسات الاستماع في الكونغرس السابقه
ترامب من البيت الابيض سوف يكون له
ولفريقه ورقه يستعملها
ويعزز مواقع اذا تم الهجوم عليه قانونيا
او سياسيا فهو فهو لديه ورقه كبيره كبيره
يقول انا كنت تحت ضغط وتدخل الاجهزه
المركزيه او الخصم السياسي لترامب
وبالتالي هذا سوف يخلق بخ يعني بقناعه
واقعه جديد في العام الان هذه التسريباته
اظهرت كيف تم تغيير السياسه الداخليه لحظر
حساب الرئيس السابق ومنعه من التغريد على
المنصه واحده وبشكل متميز عن بقيه القاده
السياسيين الاخرين
حتى اللحظه خاصه مع سياسه عدم التعليق
التي انتهجها الرئيس دونالد ترامب حول
الموضوع برمته منذ اعلاني لهم ماسك من على
حضرتك حساباته حتى هذه المعلومات التي
ربما لم تكن خفيه لدى البعض ريتا سليمان
العربيه واشنطن